pessoal primeiro eu quero agradecer
muito a oportunidade de estar aqui é um
grande privilégio é uma satisfação
enorme poder estar participando do ted
agradecer a todos os organizadores ea
todas as pessoas que tornaram esse
momento possível
eu quero falar para vocês sobre problema
oportunidade
esse é o nome do meu livro que na
verdade nem fui eu quem odeia o melhor
dei o nome do livro fez uma cacofonia
que eu escrevi uma biografia ea editora
sugeriu esse nome
quem me fez refletir bastante a respeito
da sugestão por que eu tanto eu me sinto
uma pessoa muito positiva né
e ao ler a minha história inclusive eu
fui convidada para escrever esse livro
essa biografia através de algumas
entrevistas em web mídias empresas e até
televisão em função de da minha
superação né
acontece que algumas pessoas começam de
baixo eu costumo dizer que eu comecei do
alto né
sou nascida e afirmasse de criada numa
favela ou comunidade chamada morro do
fubá aqui no rio de janeiro eu tinha uma
visão bem disse uma bem ampla
principalmente de tudo que eu não queria
podem procurar aí a casinha mais humilde
que vocês acharem bem em cima certamente
a casinha que eu morava era só de tijolo
telha de amianto e terra de chão batido
de a piso tinha mais ou menos uns 30
metros quadrados moravam seis pessoas
minha mãe era lavadeira meu pai era
motorista de trator de traga cela que
ele fazia a linha gente ia viveu grandes
apertos financeiros
é econômico os familiares né exemplos
como não tenho um sabonete para tomar
banho eram barras de sabão de lavar
roupa que era bem dividido pra dar pra
vários meses quando a coisa estava muito
boa a gente usava sabão de coco era uma
toalha para as pessoas ficarem os
últimos a tomarem banho tinha que torcer
porque é aquela história transparente
que você levanta se via do outro lado
então ao mesmo tempo era a casa que
abrigava que me escondia do sol mas não
da chuva e quando chove a gente em que
mascar chiclete pratão aos flores do
telhado e assim ali assim eu fui criada
uma família que me deu tudo que eles
puderam me dar do bom e do melhor dentro
da capacidade deles tudo o que meu pai
minha mãe puderam nos dá
eu acredito que deram do bom e do melhor
dentro da capacidade deles do que eles
podiam fazer de melhor é uma morreu eu
tinha oito anos de idade ou mais que a
gente repita a história das vezes a
gente era passada e estava sentindo
estava revivendo e às vezes nos faz
reviver e há neste momento briguei com
deus eu digo que eu era muito próxima de
deus porque eu freqüentava a igreja
tinha que é muito comum nas comunidades
e nesse momento briguei muito com deus
dia seja ruim com ele falar comigo é
capaz de cheirar uma mãe de uma família
que a gente vai fazer agora estrutura
que base ea gente ia e mergulhou no
silêncio profundo de dor e sem saber
como lidar com aquilo e meu pai não
sabia como conversar
ele era uma pessoa que não tinha ilusão
ele era uma pessoa são digitados
misturado com porcos farelo come aquela
coisa de rapazes o seguinte não faça
coisa errada aí né
era mais ou menos assim tanto é que o
meu irmão mais velho por falta dessa
instrução por falta dessa orientação uma
mente mais fraco
e com tudo isso em volta
ele acabou se envolvendo com o tráfico e
não viveu muito para ajudar a contar uma
história aqui comigo
passado um tempo rafael pai né
criou os filhos mas não tem porque vai
ele derrame infarto real dentro de casa
e só isso que tinham é um simples a
princípio ela tinha um piso no chão eu
passar pano no chão porque não dava pra
chamar varrer a casa do gaiato de terra
confesso que hoje eu tenho uma casa que
tem dias que eu não posso pano
eu tenho não no curto nem aprendi que eu
não curto mas era o meu sonho meu sonho
era ter um cabelo balançando e crede
shampoo condicionador hockey e esse
sonho eu não tinha vergonha de morar
neste lugar de medo de morar neste lugar
é por eles motivos é um deles que eu não
queria continuar vendo todas essas
coisas que aconteceram ali crescer
desenvolver
eu sabia que existia um mundo muito
melhor eu queria esse mundo pra mim eu
me sentia merecedor desse mundo também
simplesmente porque um ser humano não
importa a cor da minha pele
e aí eu conheci eu tive a oportunidade
de conhecer a ter contato com o mercado
de beleza para isso tinha que conhecer o
meu propósito né assim eu queria e
precisava sair daquela favela sair
daquela vida sair daquela situação e
realizar os meus sonhos mas o que eu ia
fazer eu não sabia que eu ia fazer da
minha vida o que as pessoas perguntam é
que profissão você mas o que você vai
ser quando você crescer não sei que
profissão você às vezes as pessoas são
forçadas a fazer uma faculdade que ela
está bem não está preparada para decidir
e aí é magro resto da vida por ter feito
uma formação que não é feliz
eu só sabia de uma coisa eu queria ser
feliz nas minhas escolhas eram pra eu
ser feliz assim que o escolhi meu marido
que está aqui é se chama e foi assim que
fui construindo as minhas escolhas não
quer morar aqui porque aqui não me faz
feliz isso aqui não me faz feliz de ter
esse meio me faz feliz de ver essas
coisas não me fazem felizes e eu
encontrar um meio de vida né a
normalmente as pessoas que moram nesse
lugar elas na opção seguinte já como
marido rico
não mas eu queria ser feliz é arrumar um
marido rico não era a felicidade que
estava buscando pra mim não era opção
para mim eu queria ser feliz com o homem
que realmente o hamas
eu tive a oportunidade de trabalhar em
alguns lugares com vendas com pessoas
assim subiu muito leque o meu campo de
visão até ter a oportunidade de conhecer
o mercado de beleza e ele está
encontrando o meu propósito que ele já
existe em mim eu só não sabia que ele
era um propósito de vida quando por
exemplo
chovia na favela e era água a morro
abaixo
aquela lama que ficava brilhante por
causa dos minerais e tinha visto na
televisão que lama medicinal era bom
para a pele capa que ele passava na pele
a pele ficar bonita é eu já tinha
vaidade já gostava dessa coisa de beleza
teve que aprender a mexer sendo com meus
cabelos na época chapinha pente quente
de fogão vai esticar os cabelos bateu
cabeça balançando pretensões acabou
balançando né
quando eu conheci o mercado de beleza eu
tive a oportunidade de trabalhar em uma
loja de cosméticos eu me senti na
disneylândia
era o meu mundo ali e me descobrir
ali eu tava descobrir meu propósito daí
depois eu conseguir montar um salão de
beleza já em parceria com um grande
homem um grande marido que é muito bom
você ter boas parcerias têm envolvido
com pessoas que vejam o que você vê que
ela não se esforça e ver o que você vê
vai te dar uma força o apoio ea irmã tem
um salão de beleza quando eu completei
meu primeiro ano naquele salão de beleza
cuidam de pessoas com a mesma sensação
o mesmo sentimento mesmo prazer do
primeiro dia de trabalho em todos os
lugares que eu tiver oportunidade eu
sabia que estava fazendo a coisa certa e
aí forte empoderada do jeito que eu
estava ali em menos de um ano eu já
estava morando em uma casa muito bacana
já tinha um carro em menos de um ano eu
fui montar o 2º salão
se não foi bom e isso não foi bom não
estava preparado
para um segundo não estava preparada
para crescer a gente pra crescer a gente
precisa ter base precisa de estrutura
precisa tá analisar de estudos
eu ainda não sabia disso porque nós não
somos preparados para os empreendedores
nós somos preparados para serem
empregados na sua maioria quando fazem
perguntas onde você vai trabalhar em uma
grande empresa com o concurso público
vai fazer né
e aí eu quebrei gente os dois salões os
dois muito rápido e fiquei devendo um
fornecedor fiquei devendo o funcionários
foi a dor do fracasso no momento quem
empreende sentir a dor a dor do fracasso
de quebrar um dia cair naquele a buraco
fundo nós nos buracos fundo eles tinham
bola né eu ficar
esse buraco chuva difícil achar uma mola
foi difícil achar a bola e aí eu fui
perdendo meu foco demissão porque eu te
encontrar a minha missão que era cuidar
de pessoas aquilo que me dava prazer é
uma missão de vida e contra meu
propósito que eu posso fazer e ainda
aliado a isso ganha dinheiro é menos um
indivíduo ou cuidar de pessoas e nesse
momento que eu fracassei fiquei devendo
sente fracassada eu caí nesse posto
nesse buraco fundo que costuma desenhar
como um túnel que muitas vezes a gente
passa e quando a gente respira e vive
aqueles problemas que seguram que
prendem a gente que não deixa a gente
radiante quando lhe perguntei o que
aconteceu porque você não vai falar
porque o problema é que o problema é que
eu vivi três meses mergulhada nesse
problema
esquece quem eu era naquele momento
porque eu conseguia naquele momento
estava vivendo a dor o fracasso
vivendo o problema e com isso não
conseguia sair do lugar
até que um dia uma pessoa me perguntou
em seu salão como vai dizer não deu
fechou a manhã o mercado está ruim a
política as pessoas produto ficou carro
fiquei devendo um fornecedor não tem
como pagar não tem dinheiro nem pra
pagar uma passagem como é que eu vou
fazer
aí ela me perguntou o seguinte cadê a
jane que eu conheço e aí eu mesmo frase
o roxo e eu mesmo me perguntei
é realmente esta pessoa que está aqui
falando isso não sou eu
alguns espíritos do mal invadiu meu
corpo está aqui falando por mim porque
esta não sou eu
eu realmente me olhei no espelho e me
questionei cá desde que eu conheço a
pessoa que é positiva que sempre vê
oportunidades quando as pessoas falam
que tão ruim eu falo não vamos ver o
melhor caminho
e aí eu me achei de volta comecei a ver
a luz e sair daquele túnel escuro e
comecei a transformar novamente aquilo
que era problema em desafio estava
vivendo o problema
e aí eu mudei a chave e transformei em
um desafio porque enquanto estava vendo
o problema não saía do lugar mas quando
transformar isso em desafio
automaticamente nosso corpo reage à
nossa mente reagir e automaticamente a
gente se pergunta agora é se esse o
desafio que eu vou fazer
se vocês são desafiados a fazer qualquer
coisa sem um atleta é desafiado a correr
xx metros com o outro que é melhor ele
vai treinar mais
ele vai procurar se desenvolver mais ele
vai ganhar força pra isso era o que eu
precisava ganhar conhecimento força
a princípio eu precisava olhar para
dentro de me reconhecer onde eu errei
assumi as minhas responsabilidades e
parar de viver o problema
o coitadinho né que normalmente a gente
acaba fazendo
e aí por conta dessa mudança de olhares
quando essa virada de chave e por isso
que a gente fala problema oportunidade
mudando olhares realizando sonhos eu
conseguir conquistar algumas coisas
olhando pra você ea primeira franquia de
embelezamento do olhar um conceito novo
não existia não existia o que era um
problema pra gente porque no meu salão
quando era pra fazer uma sobre ele ser
um problema porque é um serviço de menor
valor agregado queria fazer serviço mais
caro e quando as pessoas vão procurar
fazer a sobrancelha é um serviço que não
queria fazer porque era muito barato mas
eu fazia muito bem porque era minha
missão de vida cuidar de pessoas e o
problema a oportunidade na verdade
muitas vezes ela vem fantasiada de
problema com isso nós somos líderes de
mercado maior centro de beleza mento do
olhar do mundo é a marca construiu um
conceito
temos uma escola de formação de
profissional que isso não existia e tupi
se criar uma escola de formação
profissional que são as consultoras de
embelezamento do olhar mas também
precisei desenvolver empreendedores são
as minhas franqueados pessoas que não
foram preparadas para serem
empreendedores chefes líderes
por isso a gente tem um programa de p g
programa de capacitação gestão para
desenvolver essas pessoas para saber
como lidar com negócios para não
acontecer o que aconteceu comigo fui
buscar conhecimento consultoria
treinamento e cheio enfim não dá pra
gente desenvolver tudo isso aqui porque
a gente não tem tempo para isso
temos uma distribuidora de produtos para
atender a nossa necessidade da franquia
com produtos próprios para isso a gente
tem hoje uma indústria fabrica uma
fábrica dos nossos próprios produtos e
para 2019 nós temos planos de entrar nós
então mas a internacionalização
tudo isso por conta de uma virada de
chave
seu olhar pra frente e olhar para dentro
de você transformar os problemas e
desafios problemas aquilo que nos
paralisa desafio aquilo que te
impulsiona
vou perguntar pra vocês quanto vocês
acham que vale
essa pinça alguém fala pra mim o valor
10 centavos de reais 3 reais
vou falar pra vocês 73 milhões de reais
em 2017 é quanto vale a pensa propósito
da gente está muito na frente da gente
na cara da gente o gol ea gente fica
procurando coisa longe 73 milhões de
reais é quanto vale a pensa nos
faturamentos de 2017
a gente precisa mudar o jeito de olhar
as coisas
essa minha proposta aqui pra vocês veja
o problema como um desafio mas também
estejam preparados porque precisa
será para as oportunidade
muito obrigada